короткий інструктаж після хоч обидва я
з'їм усвідомити маршрут і на рік
з приводу ти зрозумій обстрілу сокиру можна
ви рушать і в дорогу у спеціальній
моніторингової місії в Україні
нині протікання над 660 осіп пари важливо
нечастих за поділ на сході країни
проти трьох місяців, а склад місії
уникнути практично в 2 год на прокиньте
паня пащ нарада образ е по ви на
буду ви вирішите чіп пологів животи роботу
місії всього разу організацію врахували вони
матч вона
представляє програму зрівняння
берліна глава міністерства закордонних
праворуч не матч він і заявив ще україна
втратити пріоритет організації в
2016 уроки проте крем вигулювання
конфлікту на донбасі піднімати chinois
ту дітище ніж аллу башках завдань краї
навчила організацію якушин ще давно
називав її за перовим тигром тобто
поважав і посмішкою у алли беззубу проти
вам решти руки в україни ці входить
в організацію пастей але урізала їй і
бюджет у 2016 уроки та його вдалося відбір
їх ти на рівні минуло уроку на так
і результат німецької МТС назвала успіхом
чи над ситуації на донбасі значення
образ я вважав віку ти на її знову
затягувалося а журналісти та політики
зараз навіть від берліну закладіть
чи су ми я організація поверне айкол
вишню політичну можу та зруби ти
зливна соку ворогу ливання конфлікту на
сході України